um
[Music]
hi mom hi i'm not sure what happened
there
i think i was too late
oh don't worry at all um
but yeah i went to see samantha
yesterday um and that was all good and
we kind of talked over the property and
just to make sure you know it's a bit of
a you know smooth transition
um
and yes i just kind of wanted to talk
over with you just the the contract
itself to make sure you're kind of happy
with everything um
did you manage to take a look over the
ones i sent over
yeah um
there's a couple of things but i'm not
been nothing major
um
so
i just want to check one thing though um
so obviously normally at the end of a
tenancy i would go in check for damage
charge deposits accordingly
um and then you would take or you would
come in and say can we get that fixed
and that fix whatever
um
are you planning to just take the
furniture off some lock stock and barrel
basically yes yeah that's the plan
even though some of it and i don't know
that some of it might not be in the best
condition
okay um i think i'm meeting her next
week um at the property and she's gonna
show me around and attendance and
everything and so i'll i'll kind of
discuss that without i've talked over a
price to them but obviously if things
are broken and and that kind of thing
i'll have to kind of you know just
discuss that with her and see what what
she's wanting to do about that um
but i kind of wouldn't worry about that
yourself because i'll kind of deal with
that kind of with her if that makes
sense if there's furniture that's not
good
yeah
if you're happy to just sort it directly
that's fine with me then
and then and then i just want to confirm
so it's 2400 a month yes and and then
you're responsible for the bills
yeah um
and finding the actual people who live
there
yes yeah
[Music]
and
so they've got an arrangement where a
cleaner goes in once a week at the
moment that's fine i can do that you
know weekly yeah
because i've got the downstairs flat
i've got an agreement that
um
we take care of the hallway and they
take care of the outside bit
okay
i'm not sure how well it's ever been
done because i've walked past the
property in the outside it's been a bit
messy sometimes i've gone in the
hallways definitely not been cleaned a
few times but that's supposedly the
arrangement so
so is that just just so i'm sure so the
arrangement is the the person in the
downstairs room they cleaned the outside
area and also the hall is that is that
correct
uh
no so
there's
so it's it's a it's a converted
victorian house and the property you're
taking off sam yeah is the
upstairs and
lost converted loft of that house
yeah
and so that the the bottom floor of that
house is a separate flat i don't own it
makes sense
um but the
landlady there
basically we've got an agreement that
because because
there's the cleaner the clear and so
there's a shared hallway as well you
know and it's quite small all well it
all makes sense as soon as you walk in
yeah the agreement is that
the cleaner i.e sam
or sam whoever sounds higher or you hire
also cleans that little bit
yes
yeah that's fine
yeah
it takes an extra
five minutes
yeah there was a time
but just want to make sure that's for
that um another thing so the contract
says two years and when i spoke to
samuel he said three years i'm not
fussed either way but obviously
yeah i think i think maybe yeah stop
we'll start with two and just check you
know
we're happy with everything and about
i'm sure it'll be absolutely fine um but
yeah maybe start with two and then we'll
we'll work from there
yeah cool
and then i want to check on the
arrangement with you and samuel
obviously i've i've looked up your
company there's only one director and
that's you yes
which i'm fine with but then that means
there's no connection to samuel
yes so someone's actually here right now
that's alright so
is
did you wanna
yeah
oh thanks
oh sorry and yes so i was gonna say yes
so basically i'm setting up the um
the clapham kind of side of things so we
we've done rent to rent obviously
a million times i kind of walk within
samuel's company um but this is
and this is like the side of the company
where i'll be kind of setting up in the
you know clapham kind of south southwest
london area
um
so yeah that's that's the kind of
arrangement there is anything
is there any kind of questions you have
regarding regarding that
no so it's so it's basically like i said
i don't mind it will mean because
because it's a brand new company and
because you're a brand new director
i'll ask for five weeks rent as a
deposit okay
and that's simply because if you don't
pay
any month i'll take it back straight
away because you've probably got no cash
reserves
um
but it also means as well if anything
does go wrong and obviously
i really hope it doesn't but there's no
there's no comeback on samuel's company
it's all on you yeah i wouldn't i
wouldn't worry you know i'm absolutely
happy to to pay five weeks up front and
you won't have any issues with me at all
no i i never have but it's obviously i
want to
i want you to be aware of it more yeah
that's fine um
it's it's how it is it's how it is
legally so
um
and then the other arrangement is i'm
i'm essentially pretty hands-off so
any small repairs you just
tell yourself yeah i think it was
i never get to hear about them
any of the big stuff like i had to
replace the oven quite recently
yeah that's absolutely fine so i'll put
um
a hundred pounds towards towards
anything and obviously anything small
under 100 pounds i'll just you know fix
and sort myself um
and then yeah anything anything bigger
than that i'll obviously uh get in
contact and i can still you know get
everything sorted but it'd just be you
know i'd put up to a hundred pound uh
into into fixing it
cool okay i mean look i've got i've got
no issues
um
if you're happy with all those little
changes so
next next step is meet up
sign the contracts and then sort of off
you go really yeah that i'm you know i'm
definitely happy with that and i can
make those changes to the to the
contract um
and yeah let me know when you're kind of
available to me really well i i come
down to london once or twice a week now
i always used to but i haven't for the
last 18 months or so because because of
life yeah
um
i'm actually in london on tuesday so i
could meet you on tuesday afternoon yeah
that would be perfect
yeah
tuesday afternoon
amazing what is there any kind of time
that this suits you best i think i'm
free around um
and maybe around 2 p.m at your best if
that if that would work for you
could you push that back slightly please
yeah what um
[Music]
i mean someone at one so
for probably an hour
okay
i mean we're probably only talking a
half to
and it depends where we meet as well so
that's in the center of london um i'm
happy to meet anyway to be honest okay
perfect should we say then 3 p.m
excuse me
and in terms of where where whereabouts
will you be in london at that time
piccadilly
near piccadilly um okay
let me see if there's anywhere
okay well should we shall we say 3 p.m
in uh piccadilly area and i'll look for
some work on a nearby that we can we can
go to
yeah
so it's me and i'll bring the contracts
with us
okay
perfect do you want me to make the
changes to the contract door
uh
no i can do it i'll do it tomorrow um
i'll email them back to you so you can
have a look at them and check that
you're
excuse me you're happy with everything
yes yeah
and then if anything does occur to me as
well i can i can anything else i can put
that in an email but i don't think there
will be
okay yeah that's absolutely fine um
i think that was everything uh i had to
discuss as well so so yeah i'll see you
on tuesday then
cool
lovely challenge oh lovely to talk to
you matt and i'm yeah i'm excited to do
business so
[Music]
oh